trouver de l'aide concernant son enfant
dans une même structure c'est ce que
viennent chercher les familles dans le
centre de protection maternelle et
infantile de guyancourt
le nouveau site plus adapté répond aux
exigences réglementaires et aux besoins
des usagers des professionnels le
département des yvelines a investi plus
de 160000 euros dans les travaux de
rénovation la pmi de guyancourt a été
inaugurée jeudi 8 novembre la pmi a
changé d'emplacement puisque les locaux
étaient trop petits et puis qui à un
moment là le conseil départemental avait
choisi effectivement de de fermer de
nombreuses pmi sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc nous on s'est battu sur
guyancourt avec la population pour
garder notre pays me la pmi a changé de
lieu mais est resté sur guyancourt et
donne donc la possibilité à toutes les
familles de pouvoir l'utiliser et des
familles qui sont aussi sur les
territoires juste à côté
auparavant il fallait attendre entre 4 à
6 semaines pour avoir un rendez vous
mais l'équipe du nouveau centre composée
d'un médecin de consultation trois
vacataires une sage-femme deux
assistantes administratives et c'est
depuis et reculent trice permettent un
rendez vous sous 15 jours
on va pouvoir voilà diminuer les listes
d'attentes pour le public
en proposant davantage de consultations
également davantage de permanence qui
sont des temps d'accueil sans rendez
vous cela va nous permettre également de
pouvoir mettre en place des actions
collectives donc qui était préparé
mais n'ayant pas de salle prévue à cet
effet dans les anciens locaux on pouvait
pas les mettre en place d'autres projets
vont émerger à destination des parents
la ville de guyancourt va créer un lieu
d'accueil parents enfants mais aussi un
ram un réseau d'assistantes maternelles